the end of the dream
is a radical and permanent shift in
perception
there is no longer an ability
to be lost in the entity Mirage
the vacuity has become clear home and
identity
non-temporal
non-local distributed like a web
all Dojo martial art is performed from
here
it is no longer ever left or forgotten
it is ragingly pure
radiant and empty
all day every day
it is laughable the deluded programs
that are running
everything is avoiding void
engaging in drama
if void could not Veil itself
there would be no story
the whole veiling itself into separate
parts
enables contraction and expansion
the only data that is comprehended is
perceptual
experiential
the math that the void cares about is
morphisms in seeing
seeing through the veil of separation
is what gives possibility to transform
into wholeness
all Dojo martial art is catalyzing
perceptual morphisms
whether interjecting conditioned
programs of contraction
or expanding by Breaking Free of all
boxes and limits
when complete empty freedom is fully
reunited with
no matter what the sense8 combat
the whole is never lost
a Sensei is only birthed by ending
seeking spirituality learning and
knowledge
it is an exhaustion and dissolution that
happens all by itself
there are no more dualisms conceptual
elaborations or questions whatsoever
one has fully taken back the empty
throne and closed all loops
by knowing nothing and being no one
knows everything and is everyone
this is the ultimate identity of the
whole
one infinite in Endless dance